من صمت الركام تخرج الحياه في الشمال
السوري هنا حين يسرد الصمت لحظات فزع
النازحين السوريين وهم يواجهون اللام فر
بنيران القصف التركي وطرق مسدوده بحواجز
النظام السوري اين ما القت العين بصرها في
مدينه اعزاز لا تجدوا سوا فراغ يحاول ملئه
سكانه ونازحوا المدينه هنا منازل ناجيه من
حرب فرضت نفسها منذ سنوات واستقرت الى اجل
غير معلوم
بمقابلها بيوت يصلحها اصحابها علها
تستقبلهم من جديد كل شيء بحساب في المدينه
المحاصره بالقصف والحواجز الطعام والمياه
كل شيء يستخدم ضمن حساب يوجد اصحابه ويضعف
من ضيق الحياه
كل شيء مفكر عندنا الفريق
موجود ما في مواضع اساسيه ما في حتى الخبز
مافي وكاي حرب تستمر للسنوات تتلاشى امال
الصغار وتنحني ظهور عجائزها اكثر في مدينه
اعزاز يعرف الاطفال قيمه فروع الشجر
المتلبسه ثنيرانها هي المنقذه من لفحات
البرد
سوء الاحوال الماشيه في الشمال السوري لم
يمنع اكثر من 81% من اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين
الف ناجح سوري وفق بيانات دوليه من اللجوء
الى محافظتي حلب وادلب فهي على سوء
احوالها يبدو انها تبقى افضل حالا او
بالاحرى اقل سوءا من مناطقهم حنان المصري
العربي